ce que excusez moi mais vous ne seriez
papier à palma karasin ça c'est drôle ça
fait deux fois qu'on me dit aujourd'hui
c'est c'est la coiffure je crois qu'il
fait ça le brushing qui ressent
maintenant même influence va bien
falloir vous auriez aimé ressembler à
qui quand j'étais petit à fantômas mais
c'en est étonnant pourquoi j'ai envie de
demander parce que
je trouvais qu'ils sont déguisements
étaient réussis à à répond comme si
j'étais petit alors au fond est ce que
vous vous êtes mais merci à vous lui est
ce que vous vous aimez au fond wenn man
en surface je veux bien oui oui oui oui
oui je préfère comme le disent quoi on
vous aime
merci une autre question on dans les
questions tant pis je me lance vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
j'ai une baguette magique pas déjà je me
ferais une tronche de fait pour l'heure
- coupon d'accor et non me changerait
n'entre longtemps bon je voulais tout
changer et puis maintenant je me dis que
mère je veux dire c'est rare d'être
siens grâce à gela quoi est-ce que ça
vous plaît quand vous reconnaissent dans
la rue
j'aime bien j'aime bien pas le dimanche
quand j'ai fait la fête le samedi soir
avec dimanche je veux dix ans pour
acheter mon pain tu le brushing comme ça
qu'on me demande si c'est bien kiffé ce
cas là j'ai envie de dire non
devant le reste du temps et ça me plaît
bien alexis je dirais pas que j'ai un
début d'érection mais c'est vrai que je
dit moi vous avez été obligé de coucher
pour réussir
ouais avec muriel robin est ce que vous
pensez que vous méritez ce qui vous
arrive vous croyez que ça va durer je
suis un chanteur qui a fait un tube quoi
je crois que l'humour c'est plus c'est
c'est un coup d'oeil sur la vie qu'on a
et puis qu'on garde tout en quoi tout
aussi sa maman ne regrettez vous pas
déjà d'avoir accepté d'être invité dans
cette émission
non je voudrais le faire ce soir plus
merci bien fade
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu